okay thank you for attending
and good day for all of you so um
i just want to give you a short talk
about
um the recent re finding that we had
and the title of my talk is multimodal
analysis of circulating cell free rna
circulating cell free dna genomic dna
and circulating tumor cells from blood
samples
in cancer research so my name is thorsen
foss and
i'm a research scientist in the
pre-analytics r d department from
the joint venture pre-analytics between
kaijan and baghdan dickinson
so we have in the next slide a short
legal disclaimer so that every product
that you will see
in the next slides is for research use
only
and now i come to the content of my talk
so i divided the talk in three parts so
the first part will be an introduction
in this field
what are the main topics in the in the
field of bio
liquid biopsies and i start with the
sir with the specific circumstances
about ccf dna and what's beyond of this
and then in the next two parts of the
talk i will
give you a short summary of two very
recent studies that we have done
where we focused on the multi-modality
and analysis from liquid biopsies so in
the first part we look at
a study where we where we looked on ccf
rna
excessive dna and gdna from the same
single blood sample
and in this final part i will show you a
study where we
expanded this workflow to ctc as well
so for introduction so in this first
introductory slide
i start from the beginning many of you
probably also already know this but to
have everyone on the same page
i just want to show you here this scheme
of a blood vessel with some
tumor adjacent and connected to it and
just want to remind you that we have
mainly three processes which
are important for the liquid biopsy from
blood
and these three processes are shown on
the left of this slide
which releases so it's the reason why
biomolecules are released from the tumor
into the bloodstream
so in the middle part you see a scheme
for apoptosis or peptos so the regular
cell does
is of course the main process that is
involved in
releasing compounds into the blood cells
so
apoptotic processes of course occur in
tumors
as well as in every other part of the
body and
during this regulated cell death you get
these
[Music]
regulated process of degrading genomic
dna as well of the rest of the cell
and via this you get defined
uncomfortable defined path um defined
fragments of the genomic dna the
so-called
nucleosomal fragments
in from the cell released into the blood
so these nuclear zones shown in the
blood vessel on the lower part contain
a ccf dna so circulating cell free dna
which is uh wrapped around the histones
and i'm not normally in these no
mono-nucleosomal fragment
of only of a length between 160 and 180
base pairs
so this is the main part of the ccf dna
but the op-optos processes also release
some
some particles which are
surrounded by membranes the so-called
exosomes or
nuclear or other extra
particles which are also released via
this apoptotic process
besides apoptosis we have also two um
other um two other mechanisms releasing
biomolecules into the bloodstream um the
upper one is the necrosis this is of
course important especially for for
tumor
for tumors which releasing
their compounds into the bloodstream so
this
unregulated process is a rapid
dying of the cell and with via this
process you get
other fragments of dna into the
bloodstream
which are of different lengths and but
also contain
the information from the tumor
the third process that i want to mention
here is um
the excretion process secretion process
where the cell is not dying but
secreting actively
some compounds um into the bloodstream
mainly extra um methodical uh
vehicles um which are mainly
called exosomes and these extra these
exosomes mainly contain
a circulating cell free rna so we have
these three
main compounds of liquid biopsy
molecules that
are of interest so the ccf dna as i said
a part
mainly of this monologue feature
and then a ccfrna which is mainly found
in the exosomes
and then as another important compound
of course we have
the release of complete cells from the
tumor into the bloodstream which are
called ctc so
circulating tumor cells
coming from this overview um i just want
to show you
why it is so important that we have that
we have some
kind of a standardized workflow and some
kind of stabilization
which is strongly needed to if we work
with ccf dna as well
with the other molecules i mentioned and
the cdcs
as well so what you see on this slide
here is a
picture from an actual electrophoreogram
from an
agilent bioanalyzer where we
[Music]
look at ccf dna isolated from plasma
from an edta
tube where the blood cells are directly
separated from the plasma directly after
the blood draw
and you see here the normal pattern of
ccf dna for
a healthy subject with a
main peak of ccfd name this range as i
mentioned before
of 160 to 170 base pairs
and some other smaller smaller
bands here for multimeters of this
mono-nucleosomal dna as well as some
um fragments of larger dna next to the
to the um to the upper marker of this um
this essay on the right so this is a
picture what you see
um if as it should should look like
for ccf dinner from healthy patients as
i said
um but this looks completely different
which is shown in this slide here
when you store the blood um for longer
times and what we have done here from we
have a replica sample here also
collected in eta
um and stored it for for six days
at room temperature and what happens
then is that you have an
increased massive increase of gdna
release and also
apoptotic band release from the dying
white blood cells
which is shown in this darker bluish
graph that here that is overlaid here
for the original one
and what you see here that you have a
huge release of dna into the plasma
which which covers the the
original ccf dna went overlaid so that
it is difficult
to get the original signal and find
your target molecule in this huge
background
so therefore it's very important that
you have a stabilization
of the ccf dna especially the
stabilization of the blood cells so that
they cannot
release their dna
so we and as well as other companies
developed
a solution for this so specialized
blood collection tube here in our case
it's called the pakistan blood ccf dna
the tube where you see that this tube on
the right
this has a stabilization solution in it
where you get a direct stabilization of
the cells
after with the blood draw so that it is
prevented
these cells do to release their dna into
the plasma
and overlay the cc as the original ccf
dna
so as i said these uh this
stabilization solution um prevents the
apoptosis of the white blood cells
but this also um prevents the
ptosis and the the disintegration of the
red blood cells and the hemolysis
which is not that important because of
the dna
because the red blood cells of course do
not contain
dna but the red color
of the plasma of course has some other
negative
impacts of the plasma plasma harvesting
and
as well as some downstreams can also be
impacted by a huge hemolysis
furthermore this tube has also um this
non-cross-linking feature of their
stabilization solution in contrast to
many others so we have no
uh modifications on the um on the ccf
dna
with this tube and therefore it's
compatible with very sensitive
downstream
methods as such we'll show you in the
next slides um
especially also with methylation based
essays
further features that are also important
to know is
that these tube has a plastic it's a
plastic tube so you have
a minimize of risk of breakage as well
as you have this hemoguard
closure which prevents the splattering
of the blood when you open the tube
and this of course enhances the safety
of your personal
um in the lab so
coming back to the slide that i showed
you before so
if we use such a tube so in this case
our packstream.ccf dna
for blood collection um as you as you
see it here in in this graph
we expanded the experiment by two tubes
um one packaging tube that was um
was where the plasma was directly
removed after blood draw from the cells
and one where we stored the blood for
six days similar to the edta
and then do this removal and ccf dna
isolation
and what you can see here is that the
blood
connection to the pax gene to do does
its job
so you see no release for this bluish
bluish graph here of the dna in
into the plasma so the dna the
white blood cell are preserved by the
stabilization solution
if we expand this experiment further for
example there's another
um tube from from the company's track
which is also very common in the field
and widely used
which also has a
solution in it which prevents the white
blood cell for
lysis so you see also from this here in
this
in this greenish color here
the graph that after six days to get
also
you don't see a massive release of
genomic dna into the plasma so
also this tube as is doing in its
primary job so
no release of genomic dna but what you
also see if you look a little bit closer
to the main ccf dna peak here
you see that the peak of the ccf dna
from this track tube after six days
is a little brighter and also you see
small shift
um or in in the size of the dna
which is also shown in the in the um
table on the right hand of this of this
slide where you see that we have a
slight shift
of the of the dna in size by measured by
the
agilent by analyzer and this is um
this is um because um this is the
structure
and from using a different um
methodology
different compound in the stabilization
solution so this tube um
contains them formal heterolyzing
substances and this formal height
crosslinks the
the cell membranes and therefore
prevents the gdna
to be released from the cells so this is
obviously very effective as you see from
the slide
but um as the opposite and which is
the downside of this is that this
cross-linking is of course
not a directed process it crosslinks
every
everything that is in in the blood and
therefore also some of the
ccfd name molecules are cross-linked to
other
cell compounds or plasma compounds which
is seen by this shift
and this crosslinks cannot be completely
released from
the prep so you can say okay so this is
a nice artifact and
it does this in anything mean for for my
downstream application
and yeah so we can see in the next
slide that this is the case and this is
important to know for you
so what you see here in this small study
that we have done
um is an experiment where we collected
blood from healthy donors
in three different tube types so the
packaging to
distract you from the slide before and
another third
tube from a different competitor
biometrica which has a similar
strategy as a strike tube to preventing
the gdna release so and we collected
blood from
from healthy donors in these three tubes
and then directly after blood
collection we spiked in sheer dna which
was sheared in the size of ccf dna so
170
base pairs and this dna that we spiked
in
carries mutations of the egfrt
gene so these three very prominent
mutations
um was in this in this dna
and we we spiked in a very low number of
copies so nearly a limit of detection of
the essay
that we used for for detection
and after um after seven days at 30
degrees incubation
we removed the plasma from the blood
cells and isolated the
fdma and then um have done an
essay which which can detect these three
mutations so qpcr essay
and look what what are the results and
what you see here in this
three different colors you see this
grayish
dark dark gray um color um there are
these are the um examples where we could
not detect any of
um any um of these um over we could not
detect um
the spiked in mutations so no signal no
ct for for these
rotations anymore and then we have this
dark greenish color
where we could detect the mutation as it
is
um as it is valid for for the essays so
this essay
this component
was an essay where you detect the y type
and the rotation and
build a data city to have a valid
reaction so all these dark green
samples have a valid reaction and then
we have also this light green color
where we get a ct for the mutant that we
spiked in
but this was out of the specification of
the the essay for this data city
so overall what you see from these um
after
seven days of incubation you lose a
signal
in many of this track as well as the
biometric i choose it's
different between the different essays
but you get um
for this for the pack stream at least
the signal the cp
of the of the different mutations for
nearly all of the samples
so you can really see that the chemistry
into
in the tube that you are using can have
an impact on your
on your stabilization and your essay
outcome
um so
what i showed you here is um an example
that
we we need some stabilization and we
need some standardization
because of the um to prevent um
errors that are um that can can be made
from
if you work with ccf dna and
um this is also noticed by um by
official um officials from from
different countries
and therefore um they
they decided to to finance a great
conversion with look into
the standardization of of pre-analytic
processes
where especially for for certain
compounds
and this ended up in an iso um
an iso norm which was published last
year for ccf dna isolation and this is
this is shown on the bottom of the slide
and
[Music]
within this iso isonorm there's a clear
guidance how to work with ccf dna how
this need to be standardized
okay so coming to the second part of my
talk and
to the first study that i want to show
you with respect to multi modality
so in this study we looked into
a workflow where besides ccf dna we
wanted to show
and to look where the other other
analytes from from the liquid biopsy
which are important
can be can be isolated from the same
blood sample
so we i for the workflow so we
um collected blood again in different in
different
um sample tubes so we used our packaging
tube but also some
of our competitor tubes so this track
tube that you have seen in the last
slide as well as the biometrica tube
and we also included the new strike rna2
which is
dedicated to ccf rna isolation
so we collected blood in these in these
tubes
then we stored the blood for three days
at room temperature
sometimes we also incubated it for six
days as you would see in the next slide
and then we um we centrifuged these
tubes
according to the iso standard i
mentioned before or the
instructions of the tube provider then
we
we isolated the plasma and from this
plasma we
prep the ccfr rna with three different
with three different kits so we we um
work with the exercise which is
um focusing on the um on the exosomal
the rna so we have the pre isolation of
the exosomes and then isolate the rna we
have and
we work with the micron easy kit which
um isolates the rna from the complete
plasma exosomes as well as other
external rna and then we um isolated the
from the rna from the plasma also with
the chiam circulating kit
which is um is capable of isolating the
um the rna but as well
as you see um the circulating cell free
dna
so that we have the cell the dna and rna
from the plasma
and then after the plasma prep we also
looked into the
remaining cells that um that you have
still in your tube
and we isolated the genomic dna from
from
the remaining cells as well and then we
analyzed
the content and the yield with pcr
essays to to get an idea what comes out
of it
and that is shown in the in the next
slide so
in the first part of this this study we
looked into this
short entire time course experiment we
wanted to know
how good we could stabilize the ccf with
our pectin ccf dna tube
the arm in in the plasma
compared to edta and what you see in
these
in in these graphs is on the left
three microrna assays where we
isolated micrornas the
left one is is one that is mainly
found in exosomes and the right one is
is the one that is more mainly found
um outside the exosome than the plasma
and the lead serum in the middle
is the one that is found as well in the
plasma as in in the exos
and you see that the behavior is a
little bit different between the two
different micrornas but overall you see
that you get
a relatively good stabilization for
in the texting tube up to three days
sometimes
also up to up to six days um
but always but always much better than
what you get from the
from edta and on the right you see also
an example for mrna isolation with
mrnas nearly exclusively
found in in exosomes and you also see
that
the stabilization with the packaging
tube on the right
is very good in contrast to the medita
so all we can see from this that we get
some kind of stabilization
uh for up to three days so we decided to
work
further with three-day stabilization
and that is uh shown um on the next
slide as well so
in this part of the study we looked into
what is happening
um with different tubes so we
looked in our tube again as well as to
the two straight tubes so the dna the
rna strength tube and the biometric
attribute
and how they are we can see the
how good is the the um stabilization in
these tubes
compared to time point zero and what you
see here is again you see a small
release of
of rna into the plasma or in the
exosomes
by after three days from the pectin too
but different
kinds of release in most cases
higher than the pax gene ii for the
other tubes so you see
it is important what a tube you you
you use if you are interested in
circulating separate
rna on the right in this bluish graph
you see
that we also looked in as i said in the
ccf dna so from the same plasma we
isolated the ccf dna
and you see that there we have nearly no
change for
all the tubes that we looked compared to
eta where we have a huge
release of dna as you have seen in the
first part of my talk
furthermore and finally for this study
we also looked in the genomic dna from
the
um from the remaining cells and this is
also something that
was a little bit surprising for us so we
looked into this and what we
see you get a relatively good heel for
the
for the packaging tubes after three days
and after
so directly and after three days also
for this
track dna tube a little less for the
strike rna tube okay so this uh
we were not so surprised because it's an
iona tube um
and but we we see that we have very
little yield for the biometrica tube
um and we have not a real explanation
why we see this
but furthermore we looked at the
integrity of the dna
and you see also here on the right on
the right graph here
that um from day zero to to day three we
have nearly no chain for
for the packaging tube as well for the
strike dna tube we see
little decrease in integrity for the
honey strike two but also for the
biometric a tube there's a
strongest decrease in integrity for for
this tube
okay summarizing this first multi-modal
study so i
showed you that um the non-cross-linking
technologies
for the pakistan two um enables the
isolation of of micrornas
um as well as free mrnas
and dna and genomic dna from the same
sample without any issues and with
stabilization features
and um we have seen that some of the
other tubes
have negative impact on the ccf
um dna stabilization as well as the
microanimated gdna
okay so coming back to the overview so
um and now in the final part of my talk
i
like to show you the second study for
multi-modality so
in this study we expanded these
multimodal
workflow further to the
analysis of ctcs
so for the workflow um and then for the
workflow overview i don't
want to explain what we have done so we
collected again
blood in our vaccine that ccf dna 2
and then we used the atna test
technology from kyogen to isolate
ctcs from this so we spiked in our
blood from the healthy donors tumor
cells
in this blood and then incubated for
certain times and temperatures
and then we used an antibody
coated magnetic particles where we
then isolate the uh or enrich the ctcs
from the blood um isolate them via
magnets
and on the other part of the workflow we
we then
put it in the upper test workflow like
these
ctc enriched fraction um and did
tpcr and looked in the specific targets
um from from these circulating tumor
cells
and so we could analyze the ctcs and
then
from the rest of the tube after the ctc
depletion
we spun the tube isolated
the plasma and then again isolated the
ccf dna from the cells we isolated the
genomic dna
to have this in more detail we look
first at the ctc workflow so
we as i said so we collected the blood
then we spiked in 20 cells
in into this blood and the
pakistan.ccfdna tube then we stored this
tube
um either for in the fridge for for two
to eight
degrees celsius or at room temperature
and
um then we store this for a different
time time so that we could look at three
after three hours 24 hours
48 and 72 hours storage then we
um isolated the and enriched the um
the ctc from the from the whole blood
and
put the ctc then through these test
prostate
cancer panel for r for ar
v7 and if it
and then in the next slide we see the
results so
on the left we have the cooled uh
storage and on the right the room
temperature storage
and you see um the green color here is
the foreign positive test and the red
for
for negative tests and you see that um
after three hours we could detect for
all fabric as well as after 24 hours
so there we for all surfaces were
positive so we could detect
the spiked in cdc's um and then
after 48 and 72 hours we get some a few
samples that we could not detect the
cdc's anymore but for the most of them
we still can
can um can detect the ctc's that we
spiked in
this is true for for um cool storage as
well as room temperature storage
but for cool storage we see a little a
little higher
amount of farmers which were positive
for the ctc so which
we can use so that we decided that we
should use um
fridge storage in the fridge if we want
to have
longer storage and then in the next step
we looked into
um longer longer time
course experiments so up to 144 hours
what happens there and you see here on
the right
that if you store it for even longer
times um that then
the number of samples where you could
not detect the ctcs anymore is
increasing so
we decided that the best workflow for
our tube so the packaging blood ccfd
needed to
would be a good storage for 2 to 8
degree
and then up to 72 hours so after
we um we established this workflow we of
course looked into
what is happening if we do this in a
similar way with
competitor tubes here and we again shoot
this track tube here
strike dna tube to have a side-by-side
comparison
so for both tube then we use the same
workflow so we
spiked in again 20 cells in both tubes
then we
used the optimized workflow so as i said
for the pack stream we use the
cool storage for strike we used room
temperature so because
in this track literature we found that
they
they say that the best
storage is at room temperature so we
want to choose optimize
conditions here then again we start for
these different time
times up to 72 hours again isolated the
ctcs
from the blood and and use the
test prostate cancer panel
okay so the results look like this so on
the left you see the pax gene
tube results on the right this track
tube results and
we see again that we could could use
here
we find a very good result even after 72
hours
but the new result is here for this
track tube that we see
we could detect the ctcs after three
hours storage but
already after 24 hours and also for the
longer times
we could not detect the ctcs for any of
the
straight tubes that we are used so this
is obviously not
possible for a longer charge with this
tube
okay so summarizing this part of the
second study so
um we have seen that uh for the
non-cross-linking reagent the packaging
tube
is compatible with rna analysis from
ctcs with this admirer test
panel and we propose the best workflow
is that
two to eight degree storage and we could
detect it
more or less completely up to 72 hours
so for the formal head releasing strike
tube
reagent we saw that this is definitely
not compatible
with this ctc workflow um if you if you
have to store the tube for
longer than three hours um okay
so and then um this is the ctc part of
the workflow and then as i said so we
also looked
as this is a multi-modality
multimodality workflow
we looked also in the in the other
liquid biopsy
molecules so we looked into the plasma
on the right
here and also on the cells and first we
showed you the results for the plasma
part so from the plasma we isolated the
ccf dna
and for this we um we used um on one
hand these greenish
samples where we have which
which was used for the complete workflow
so including the cdc depletion
via the other test and we also use some
control samples where we have no
ctc depletion done with them and compare
them side by side and what you see here
with respect to the yield so you see
on the y-axis here then on the x-axis
the different
storage temperatures so much time and
you see that
for both the sample times you have no
significant difference so you so you can
successfully isolate ccf dns still
after ct ctc depletion and enrichment
from from these tubes and finally
in this last part of this workflow we
also looked
into the gene into the g dna so we
isolate g dna from the remaining cells
and also here you see in a similar
pattern samples as control with no
ctc depletion and is in green the ones
where you depleted
the ctcs and you see that there is no
difference between
with respect to the gene gdna here that
you get from from these cells
um also not in the with respect to gdna
priority
so concluding this study i showed you
that
ctc depletion had no significant
impact on ccf dna health and in-situ
stability
so i showed you as well that cdc
depletion
um had had no institutions that had no
impact on ctnc to stability
on the yield of extracted genomic dna
and
that we um let the um
that this non-cross-linking region in
the packaging tube enables
um the three-in-one so to say uh
simultaneous enrichment
of ctcs and then further ctccf dna
isolation and gdna of isolation from the
same
single blood sample
okay coming to the the very last of
the last slide of my talk so overall
conclusion of my talk and the three
parts so
um i showed you that the analytes and
liquid biopsy like ccfdna
ccfrna and ctcs have a strong need for
stabilization if you
want to analyze them and that the whole
workflow needs standardization
so you um this is documented for example
in this new iso norm for ccfd in
isolation
further um iso norms and standards are
on the way
in this media consortium that i
mentioned before
so i also showed you that the
non-crosslink stabilization reagent
and the pakistan ccf dna2 enables
detection of low bundle target molecules
as
i've showed you for this qpcr with a
different egfr mutation
and this ensures that you have a
sensitive
reaction sensitive detection of these
targets
in your downstream reaction and finally
i could show you
with the two studies here that the
paxium
blood ccfd nhu allows multimodal
analysis
for ccfd as well as ccfrna
gdna and ctcs from a single blood sample
okay so with this i'm at the end of my
talk
and um thank you for your attention
and happy to answer your questions thank
you